could we survive being flipped through
the fourth dimension we would become our
Mirror Image including everything inside
of us our body's proteins hinge on
specific building blocks amino acids
these come in two Mirror Image kinds L
and D whilst we primarily use l amino
acids in our body flipping through the
fourth dimension would transform them
into D amino acids at first glance we
might think that our proteins would
still function but here's the catch our
miror proteins won't be able to break
down the food we eat though some D amino
acids exist in our normal diet they are
scarce in a lemon there are these five D
amino acids present but in tiny relative
quantities and we might not be able to
find all of the ones that we need it
seems like we might have to ask a
friendly 40 creature to also flip some
food for us to eat